في مثل هذا الوقت من يوم غد سيكون المنتخب
المغربي على موعد مع التاريخ بلقاء فرنسا
في نصف نهائي كاس العالم مدرب المنتخب
المغربي وليد الركراكي يبدو مفعما بالحماس
والثقه قبل خوض المواجهه المرتقبه امام
فرنسا حامله لقب النسخه الاخيره من
البطوله
قال خلال مؤتمر صحفي اليوم انه بالوصول
الى قبل النهائي يجب ان تكون متعطشا خاصه
وان الوصول لهذا الدور ليس متاحا للجميع
واضاف مدرب المنتخب المغربي ان فريقه لديه
رغبه بان يضع افريقيا على قمه العالم وهي
ستكون المهمه يوم غد رغم الثقه هذه اكد
الركراكي ان كل الترشيحات تصب في مصلحه
فرنسا لكن المنتخب المغربي لديه ثقه كبيره
بالنفس وقال انه ربما تعتبر الث فنونا لكن
القليل من الجنون ليس سيئا وليد الركراك
شدد على انه يطمح للمزيد من الانجازات
ليكون مصدر الهاما للاجيال القادمه
لذلك كما قلت في بدايه المسابقه نحلم
بالفوز بكاس العالم وكل ما تقدمنا اكثر
اقتربنا من حلمنا لذلك غدا سنكافح للمضي
قدما نحن واثقون حتى لو صارت كل التوقعات
ضدنا ربما نكون مجانين ولكن من الجيد ان
تكون مجنونه
مباراه الغد تشمل مباريات داخل المباراه
اي تنافسن بين اللاعبين في المنتخبين ربما
يكون الابرز فيها تواجه كيليان مبابي
واشرف حكيمي اللاعبان يرتبطان بصداقه قويه
في باريس سان جيرمان لكن مدرب المنتخب
المغربي قال انه لن يضع خطه استثنائيه او
طريقه لايقاف لاعب واحد فبحسب الركله اكيد
يضم المنتخب الفرنسي اداءا جماعيا رائعا
كما انه يضم لاعبينا بامكانهم تشكيل خطوره
على المنتخب المغربي وفيما يتعلق بمواجهه
حكيمي و مبابي قال ركراك انه لن يقدم
نصائح معينه لحكيم لان اللاعب المغربي
يعرف زميله اكثر ويتدرب معه بشكل يومي في
باريس اثناء وجودهما معا لكن هذا الامر لا
يعني ان يقدم احدهما هديه للاخر خلال
ابراهيم ابراهيم
لسوء الحظ بالنسبه لنا هناك اكثر من مجرد
كليا فرنسا لديها لاعبون جيدون اخرون
جريزمان في قمه مستواه ويلعب بشكل جيد بين
الخطوط وعثمان ديمبلي هو ايضا مكمل مثالي
لمباقي في الجناح الاخر اذا ركزنا فقط على
مبابي فسيكون هذا خطا كبيرا اشرف حكيمي هو
احد افضل اللاعبين في العالم لذلك ستكون
مبارزه كبيره بين الاثنين انهم ابطال
العالم مع لاعبين من الطراز العالمي
وسيحققون ذلك بكل ما لديهم نحن بحاجه الى
التركيز على ما يمكننا القيام به لاحداث
مشاكل فرنسا